have you ever seen a pair of headphones
that has air purification
well now you have this is Dyson Zone
they are noise canceling headphones with
a personal air purifier or
they can just be headphones if you want
[Music]
Dyson is a leader in the industry and
quite often they are found pushing the
boundaries when it comes to creating
products they're mostly known for their
vacuums and futuristic looking air
purifiers they've also entered the Hair
Care lighting space and now the
headphone space but these aren't just
any normal headphones these are the
Dyson Zone headphones and personal air
purifier with up to 50 hours of battery
life Advanced noise cancellation and a
high efficiency filtration system that
allows you to tackle pollution on the go
these definitely feel like a product of
the future but they're here right now
inside the ear cups are micro
compressors and filters these will
capture 99 of Airborne particle
pollutants which include nitrogen
dioxide sulfur dioxide and Airborne dust
this has been something that Dyson has
been working on for over six years with
their main goal of reducing noise and
air pollution for the wear now to do
this obviously there were a lot of
challenges like how do you make a great
sounding pair of headphones that are
comfort portable while combining that
with dice especially of air purification
well it looks like we have the answer so
my friends let's unbox it and see what's
inside before we start testing these out
wow look at this case this is so
industrial let's open it up and check
these out we are greeted with oh my
goodness it's got like a little carrying
case here's the strap like this case is
so nice I would actually carry this as a
bag like as a purse very nice
so we have a few components to this this
is the visor so this is the actual air
purifier piece that attaches to the
headphones itself and what I love about
this from the things that I've seen and
read about it is this doesn't actually
touch your face it kind of just hovers
in your breathing zone so it's not
hindering like your your face movements
like you can you can be a person while
you have your purified air so here's the
visor I love that this has the the
copper accents
so pretty oh my goodness I love it so
much then inside we have the headphones
this case is so incredibly nice like I
can't get over it I love the look of
them I like that this has kind of like a
little see-through ear cup and inside
these ear cups is actually where the air
filtration happens so before we turn
them on let's see what else is inside
these boxes we have it looks like all of
our instructions a quick start guide
which definitely gonna need that oh
we've got all sorts of accessories we've
got a nice little carrying bag so if you
don't want to have that hard shelled
little bag you can take this one on the
go which I definitely will be doing look
at this oh this is something I'm
actually quite excited about they have a
travel adapter for airplanes I also like
that they offer a wired connection this
is huge because as someone who edits and
kind of really does need to rely a lot
on timing I sometimes don't like editing
with Bluetooth because there is a slight
lag so this is great that we have an
option in to have it wired and I love
the color of this braided cable we've
also got another braided USBC cable and
this is for charging the headphones and
we have the air filters now these go
inside the ear cups and this is what
filters out the air before it gets to
your face let's install our air filters
now there is a my Dyson app so we are
going to connect this to our phone and
with that you'll be able to tell the
quality of the air filters and when you
will need to change these they say these
should last up to a year
oh this is nice they gave you an extra
set so the one bag there's actually two
of them inside
let's turn them on and get them synced
up to the app oh my gosh it's telling me
to put them on okay prepare our visor to
prepare remove the sleeve and fully
extend
that's it
that was it oh
the thing that I do like about this is
it's telling me about the air quality
that's around me and it's saying the air
quality is actually pretty good this I
feel like is not something that you
would be wearing indoors unless you have
some sort of air pollution problem in
your home and if that's the case then
you should probably get that looked at
so to turn on active noise cancellation
you double tap and this will reduce the
background around you and you double tap
to cycle between modes there's also an
audio joystick so I can control my audio
using the joystick on the back of the
right ear cup and there's a voice
assistant whoa oh my gosh I just
switched to transparency because when I
do have the transparency off I'm hearing
kind of all around me and there's
obviously fans running to filter this
air to your face to give you that air
filtration and the purified air I hear
something like a small slight hum you
might actually be able to hear it
yourself but for the most part
especially when I turn on the isolation
like I can feel it but I don't really
hear it so since the air quality is
pretty good in my home I'm going to just
take these off
the fans automatically stop the air is
obviously no longer blowing on my face
uh and now I've just got a high quality
set of headphones so let's listen to
some music
whoa okay
we've got music
sounds
very good these are actually very
comfortable for how large they look
there's like perfect distribution of
weight on my head and this is so light
I'm yelling because I have the music up
very loud thing that is so cool is how
quickly this just snaps on and off these
are so interesting to me because I do
feel like that in a lot of areas
depending upon where you live busy
cities I think about when I go to New
York how disgusting I feel just
breathing the air from big cities this
is something where you'll be wearing the
headphones indoors to work to edit to
take phone calls and then when you go
out on your daily commute or if you're
just out and about in a city that's when
you can pop the visor on I love that
this is so lightweight too so adding
this to your backpack or your purse
it'll barely add any weight at all not
only are you getting the benefits of
noise cancellation and noise pollution
but you're also getting that added
benefit of reducing air pollutants as
well so right now I'm doing a software
update and when that is done I'm
actually heading out on a trip so I'm
going to be really excited to test these
out on a plane in various cities and in
different scenarios where I think this
would be most fitting
[Music]
one of the things that I thought was
awesome while testing these out for the
first time in Seattle was as I was
walking faster it's able to determine
your breathing rate and deliver more
purified air to you as needed so this is
the first time I'm experiencing that
it's so cool
[Music]
oh
so I am back now from traveling and
testing out the Dyson Zone headphones
and personal air purifier and I'm gonna
tell you that I'm actually way more into
this than I thought I was at the
beginning like when I first started this
video I thought this was an incredible
concept I thought this would be
something really great for people who
live in cities who do commutes but then
as someone who travels a lot on an
airplane I could not tell you how
awesome this was to fly with I did
travel to Seattle to Pennsylvania so
while I was in Seattle I did take these
around outside going for a walk and just
kind of wearing them to see what it
would be like to wear on a daily commute
I was in Redmond which is actually a
pretty clean City all things considered
so being able to take my phone out and
actually see on the app what the
pollution levels are while you're in a
location is one of my favorite features
the other thing that I really liked was
how easy it is to switch from active
noise cancellation to transparency mode
so if I was crossing the street or I
wanted to be able to get some of the
sound that was around me and not stop
listening to my music I could do that as
well when you do first see these they
look a little silly I mean you can't
deny that it is something that is not
the norm so obviously when something
looks a little bit different people are
going to look and ask questions and I
was actually so surprised no one said
anything to me on the plane nobody even
looked at me no one said anything in
Seattle there wasn't a single person
that was even like paying any attention
and I think that's the interesting thing
about well basically us as humans is
most of the time we're the ones that are
more concerned about what other people
think when in reality no one actually
cares so for me my own health and my
comfort means so much more than what
someone else thinks about what I'm doing
I'll put a link in the description if
you guys want to get more information or
to purchase these now when I was
thinking about the price point of these
These are about a thousand dollars a lot
of high-end headphones are within the
500 to 700 range and so on so not only
you're getting high quality audio but
the fact that you're getting this added
bonus of a personal purification device
it kind of makes sense Jenna
you haven't tried these yet oh my gosh
are they so cool I like the color I know
they're awesome well thank you guys so
much for watching if you haven't already
please like comment and subscribe if you
enjoyed this video and I will see you
guys in the next one bye
foreign